ENT TRI
AS TATES
NEARS CORONUS  AMONG TRUMP SUPP?
ELLE REEVE VISITED ALARGELY CO
TENNESSEE FOSSTOR>> Reporter: N
SURGES THROU R PARTS OF
THE COUNTRY.
AND THE DEBATE IS AS
>> I WANT TO WEAR A MASK.
>>orter: WE THE SAME TO
THEACCINE.
REACHEDTENNESSEE.
>> WE'RE NOT GOING TLOCH.
>> THERE'SBLE
TO PT A VA
THAT DSNN GOINGIT.IEVE AOVNM
SHOULD TELL ME HOW T  IN OR MY
ARMS.
>> Reporter: NOT TDLE THEAD OF
ALL O N THATCO I'M NOT WORRIED
>> I'MREAL.TH IS NOT.
>> Reporter: I DON'T UNDERSTAND
WHY YOU SAY THE PANDEMIC ISREANO
PANDEMICIS?OT
>>ep YOU
K --
PANDEMIC IS?
R IT?
NO PAND. NPANDEMIC.
>> WHA>> NOT WHAT WE'RE NG CLEA
DISEASE THAT SPREADS ACROSS MANY
COUNTRIES AND AFFECTS MYE HEALT
MARCH AND EXPERTS SAY ABOUTEOEE
VACCINE TO CONTROL COVID>> IT'S
HAPPENH IT.
LATER HELP  BUT IN
THE FUTURE IT COULD CAUSEOR T YF
AGAIN.
IERSONALLY IT'S A
CHOICEorter: SOME PEOPLE AT THIS
SERVICE SAID THEY'D SEEN HIM ON
FACEBOOK AND MESSAGE.
>> DONALD TRUMP WON ELECTIOBY L
ELECTED AS PNT OF THE
UNITED ATES.>>ED KNOWW WESWS AR
THFAIROUS ABOUT RUNNING  AND DY
D FIRST RESD NURSING F AND IF TS
ANY R IT.EVERYTHING HERE IS
SQUEAKEALET ME TOU M
WA T M BIEANYTHING YOUEAF  YOU .
IT'S BEENEVELOPED VERYAPIDLY
ANAKES PEOPLE CAUTIOUS.
>> Ror BASED OUREC
INTERVIEWS AND POLLING
PAINORIT THERE'S A GROWI VACCIN
NATIONWIDEDI
REPUBLICANS.
RINSAKE ANDRLY HALFF TE RELUCTA
THEY'D GET IT AFTER OTHERS DOSO.
DR. WILLIAM SHAFNEHO
WORKING ON INFECTIOUSEASES
AT VANDERBILIV SINCE
THE '6 SS TO BUIST.>>CT LE RESPS
AND TND TO THEIR
CONCERNS.
>> WE GIVECOWS AHE YOU DO GET R.
IF WE GIVE SLOT TOD I THERE 20 .
>> AFTER THE FIRST R TA IT, WHE,
WILL YOUVACCINE?
>> I PROBABLY WILLO AND
TAKE THEOU ABOUT THE
>>THT BEEN GUI.
AND REALLY WISH THERE WAS TIMERT
O.OL TIMES BUT IT SHOULDN'T  A
THIS, AND IT WILL NOTE EASYOCHAN
T MYNGGA DO THEY UTCH MY OSOT
ITte EXPECT THEM